Austin tonight, Elon
Musk banning
multiple tech journalists
from Twitter with no explanation.
The suspensions come just hours
after Twitter
shut down an account
belonging to
an emerging competitor, Mastodon.
The ban includes
The New York Times's Ryan Mack,
The Washington Post's
Drew Harwell,
and our own CNN's Donie O'Sullivan.
Here with me to talk about all this,
we have John Berman.
Also Tony O'Sullivan
and CNN's Oliver Dorsey.
What did you do that was so bad, Tony?
We reported on Elon Musk.
We were talking about the world's well,
formally the world's
richest man, world's second richest man
who runs Twitter.
He has taken particular
a hybrid.
Yes.
He's been annoyed
that there has been this account,
which has been active for years now,
which tracks the movements
of his private jet. Right.
But you're not doing that.
Why didn't you get banned?
So we reported how yesterday
he shut that account down.
And tonight we continued to report on it.
He is claiming on social media that
I and other journalists
shared the precise
live location of his jets.
And therefore,
that's why he kicked us off,
because we cause danger to him.
Certainly my case, I didn't
we we just posted
stories about what was happening,
him shutting down those accounts.
But, look, I think the bigger issue here
is, of course,
this is supposed to be the guy
who's the free speech absolutist. Right.
Are you saying
that Elon Musk is saying
something that isn't true?
I think that seems to be the case.
I mean,
it goes actually goes
further than that, John.
He's he was touting,
I mean, freedom of speech as this beacon.
That Twitter
would be a beacon of that
until it comes to anybody
saying something
about something he doesn't like.
There's a word for that democracy.
It might be called hypocrisy.
Yeah.
Look, first of all,
Elon Musk's
understanding of freedom of speech
has always been somewhat limited.
There's no
constitutional freedom of speech
for a private company.
Never has been.
And as far as I know,
there never will be.
So his criticisms of Twitter
from before were off base
It's his company.
I mean, he can ban Dhoni if he wants to.
It's just wildly hypocritical.
Oliver,
what is CNN going to do about this?
Well, I think this raises a big question
about what
the free press,
what the future
of the free press on Twitter looks like.
You know,
our news organizations
are going to stand by
as the reporters are just
you know,
hastily banned without explanation.
CNN is saying it's
going to reevaluate its relationship
with Twitter based on the response
it gets.
I want to read you
the full statement Alison. It says,
The impulsive and unjustified
suspension of a number of reporters,
including CNN's Donie
O'Sullivan, is concerning
but not surprising.
And it goes on to say, Twitter's
increasing instability
and volatility, volatility should have
should be of incredible concern
for everyone who uses Twitter.
And then it goes on to say,
we have asked Twitter for an explanation
and we will reevaluate our relationship
based on that response.
And I think it's so important
to point out
that Twitter really needs
are really relies on news.
I mean, that's
what's kind
of the lifeblood of journalists.
I mean, they're all on Twitter.
And so
if you see news organizations
start to pull their reporters,
pull their brand accounts,
pull their content off of Twitter,
you know,
that's going to be
a real blow to the platform
and make it less usable
I think, for the average person
doing my job here.
And to play
devil's advocate against myself, I guess.
Look, when Trump got suspended,
everybody pointed out
that that was also, you know,
a concerning thing
for many people kicking off the
then president of the United States,
regardless of the circumstances.
But, you know, I have a platform.
I'm here talking to you on CNN.
There are other social media platforms.
The First Amendment,
despite what Musk
and a lot of his supporters
say, does not actually apply to Twitter.
I think what is more concerning
here, though, is independent journalist,
freelance journalist
all around the world,
many of whom are covering
maybe abuses and ongoing,
that Musk's other companies Tesla Space
X, think about the chilling effect
that might have because as Oliver said,
many journalists
rely on Twitter to get their work out
there, particularly
if they are independent freelancers.
But furthermore,
one of the things that I think
where the hypocrisy comes in
is that a lot of people felt that
hateful, vitriolic, violent speech
shouldn't be allowed on there
because of personal safety.
Elon Musk doesn't
want his personal safety violated.
I mean, that's what it comes down to.
He doesn't want people to know
where he is.
It's not personal safety
when it's about him.
He doesn't like it so much.
Look, I I said this before you.
Elon Musk
is a very successful businessman.
He's a rich guy.
He's a rich guy
who bought a media company.
But because he bought a media company
doesn't mean he understands a thing
about the media business
or about how this all works.
And I think he's just proving that again
and again and again.
If I basically think we should say that
he is actively smearing people
like don't saying
that they effectively posted
assassination coordinates on him
for reporting on this Elon
jet account, that's obviously not true.
Totally false.
But that's why you're hearing him
say on Twitter tonight.
Also, the location of his address
is publicly available information.
Yeah. Wow.
I mean, that again, it's all been right.
Don't you have to be careful?
Always bring us down with you here.
I always thought I get banned for
my bad jokes.
But no, that really adds
another wrinkle to it.
Gentlemen, thank you very much.